You ready? Here's why.
You guys ready? Now, let's learn. Now,
we're going to learn. Because they're
going to bring this up. If Jesus is God
by nature, how is it he becomes better
than angels and he inherits a name more
excellent, superior than theirs? Here's
why. Hebrews 2 5-9. For he did not
subject to angels the world to come
concerning which we are speaking but one
has testified somewhere saying
what is man that you remember him or the
son of man he's quoting Psalm 84-6
you are concerned about him you have
made him a for a little while lower than
the angels here you have made him for a
little while lower than the angels who
mankind kind who sons of men, children
of men, who human beings,
you have crowned him with glory and
honor, though mankind after the fall
are lower than angels only for a little
while,
you have crowned them in glory and honor
and have appointed him over the works of
your hands. You put all things in
subjection on his feet. So number one,
after the fall, humans, sons of men
have become less than the angels in
glory. But that will only be for a
little while because God intends to once
again crown humans with glory and honor
so they rule over his works. This is why
I want you to pay attention.
For he did not subject to angels the
world to come. The age to come
will not be ruled by angels. Then why
should it shock you that Jesus
when he became human
he became a little lower than the
angels? He shared in our status here.
For in subjecting all things to him
humanity he God left nothing that is not
subject to him. But now we do not yet
see all things subjected. What does that
mean? Right now in this age, we don't
see the world
subjected to believers, right? We have
unbelievers ruling over us, oppressing
us, killing us, imprisoning us. We have
demonic powers still influencing the
world, working through human agents. So
then how do I know and what assurance do
I have that the world to come the new
heaven or earth that angels will not be
ruling over it? We believers if we're
faithful will be glorified and crowned
and that we will rule over the world and
them.
How do I know what guarantee? Jesus. But
now we do not yet see all things subject
to him. But we do see him who was made
for a little while lower than the
angels. Jesus
Jesus when he became man entered the
world and assumed our lowly estate and
allowed himself to be positionally less
than the angels that he created. But now
that he suffered death, he now is
crowned with glory and honor. Now
understand what that means, right?
Christ is the guarantee and the
fulfillment of this promise.
He became the son of man. He became man
in order to taste death for all of us.
So that now in him we are now reconciled
and exalted to the status we had before
sin entered the world. Which will tie in
with Christ's victor. See, I'm tying
both of these together.
The atonement of our Lord is to undo the
curse of the fall.
So that when Adam and Eve sin, they lost
their glory and status, became subject
to the powers and heavenly realms
becoming less than the angels. This is
all going to tie in this. They're both
related. That's why I'm tying them
together. Our Lord in his love come and
taste death for all of us in order to
destroy
Satan's
power over us, set us free from bondage
to Satan, and then reconcile us to God
and restore us to that position of glory
that we had in Adam but lost it in him.
Yes, the Lord became superior to angels
because he became a son of man and
shared in our lowly estate and allowed
himself to be lower than the angels he
created for a little while. And then
when he died and rose, he now
became exalted over them.
Now you understand the answer.
And when did he become lower than the
angels? Therefore, since the children
share in flesh and blood, he himself
likewise also parttook of the same.
because he became flesh in order to die
a human death in order to swallow up
death by his resurrection and destroy
Satan's authority over us that through
death he might render powerless him who
had the power of death that is the devil
this will tie in with Christ's victor so
now do you understand why our lord
became superior to angels let's look at
it but now we men and women in Christ
will be crowned with glory and honor and
be greater higher than angels. But we do
see him who was made for a little while
lower than the angels, Jesus. So when
Christ returned to heaven,
when Christ returned to heaven, he
returned as a glorified man, which is
going to be the further cremation of
this clown. What do I mean?
The Lord destroyed death. How? By
swallowing of death. by his
resurrection. Everyone got what I just
said?
When did our Lord
become better than angels and obtain a
more excellent name than they? When he
sat down at the right hand of the
Majesty on high.
You got it.
after purging our sins, cleansing our
sins, he then ascended and he sits on
the right hand of the majesty on high.
That's when he becomes better than them
positionally.
What do I mean positionally? He now is
positioned
alongside of the father as the king of
heaven and earth. and therefore has
become better than them in position.
So what is the name that he inherited?
The name that he inherited that makes
them better than them is the authority
he received after being crowned as king.
So what does it mean he obtained a more
excellent name? He obtained a more
excellent rank,
a superior position,
status, authority. Why? Because he went
from a lowly estate to now ruling as
king over them. Where's the problem,
dude?
Why is this a problem?
How does this refute our beliefs?
Does that refute what we believe?
Of course, he obtained a more excellent
name and that he obtained a superior
status, rank, position, authority over
them when he went from being a servant,
assuming a lowly status to being exalted
above angels to sit in throne with the
Father on high.